American football a jackhammer of
commercials momentarily interrupted by
men in spandex throwing around a funny
ball it's a sport of skill speed and
slapping one another on the butt and
like anything American you know and love
it's full of scandal this year domestic
violence is out but
performance-enhancing drugs are in
everyone wants to play better harder
faster but is there a softer side to the
NFL is there a soft side to the NFL not
really do you ever just want to hug your
opponent how did my opponent ever what
is your favorite moisturizing routine
like what do you like are you a vitamin
E guy are you like a cocoa butter guy uh
just the Jergens day-to-day use hey
what's the first person who ever broke
your heart broke my heart hey remember
uh so there was no like sixth grade
crush there was no like putting a little
Valentine into someone else's box and I
had a crush on Trina now I'm just you
know Trina yeah baby Trina now you know
girl so you got a huge night coming up
there's so much pressure to perform on
this evening how do you deal with the
nerves of Valentine's Day haha
Valentines oh you know my wife she's
actually really true no candles no music
no music what about the main event is
there any pressure to perform at that
main event no pressure comes easy to you
uh-huh when it's gay anytime I show up
the main event you get you let your wife
take the reins there and you know you
just kind of you'd be thankful for
example you would never consider using
performance-enhancing medicine or drugs
for that main event no never is there
any stigma around that no I mean is if
you need
what about for the Super Bowl oh that's
different have you heard of people who
are using performance-enhancing drugs as
well not have it I mean not nothing that
you guys haven't heard you know as far
as somebody I know personally that uses
it no I've never had to make me play
better I'm thinking about it because I
kind of want to get big in the next like
six months and so like what kind of
performance-enhancing drugs would you
recommend for me like look at these arms
I got nothing going on here let's say
your micro Josie human growth hormone
would you be able to pass a randomly
test at an even moment excuse me now
I've been hearing a lot of controversy
over HGH why is everyone so upset over
home grown herbs do you have a favorite
romantic comedy um no how to lose a guy
in 10 days okay I'm calm you just go to
like romantic comedies because your wife
or your girlfriend or significant other
months ago you don't really go to go
like deep down when the music swells and
there's that kiss you're just kind of
you kind of smile right uh you know what
you know at the end of South Pole I
cried me and my wife cried together
you